die internationalen Nachrichten wurden
zuerst vom Krieg in der Ukraine und dann
vom hamasanschlag in Israel dominiert
allerdings sind das nicht die einzigen
aktuellen Krisenherde denn die Tendenz
ist eindeutig die Welt wird immer
instabiler die Zahl der Brände nimmt
ständig zu ganz genau wir werden uns in
dieser Dekade verdammt warm anziehen
müssen eine weitere Region die uns ganz
bestimmt keine Pause gönnen wird ist der
Kaukasus hier auf visualpolitik haben
wir schon einige Male über diese kleine
und konfliktreiche Region berichtet die
Kriege in chechinien und das
kalirovreime der russische Einmarsch in
Georgien 2008 und die neue für die
Europäische Union wichtige Rolle
Aserbaidschans im Energiebereich all
diese Videos findet ihr unten in der
Beschreibung verlinkt diesmal geht es
allerdings um das mögliche Ende des
längsten eingefrorenen Konflikts im
gesamten postsowjetischen Raum wir
sprechen natürlich über den Konflikt in
Bergkarabach und ihr erinnert euch
sicher alle daran dass wir vor nicht
allzu langer Zeit Nachrichten wie diese
gesehen haben Aserbeidschan startete
einen Angriff auf separatistische
Gruppen in Bergkarabach dem umstritten
Gebiet mit Armenien tatsächlich meine
Lieben Zuschauer scheint es so als ob
dieser bittere Konflikt nach mehr als 30
Jahren endlich ein Ende gefunden
hat Bergkarabach diese kleine Bergregion
zwischen Armenien und Aserbeidschan die
hauptsächlich von Armenien bewohnt wurde
ist von aserbaidschanischen Truppen
eingenommen worden und okay viele von
euch werden sich vielleicht fragen was
geht mich das überhaupt an nun was wäre
wenn ich euch sagen würde dass die
Eroberung von Karabach durch
Aserbaidschan ein großer Sieg für die
Türkei ist und was wäre wenn ich
behaupten würde dass dies eine mega
Niederlage für Russland ist und was
würdet ihr denken wenn ich euch sagen
würde dass dies zu einem ernsten
Konflikt zwischen Israel und den Iran
führen könnte denn so klein das Gebiet
auch sein mag die Realität ist dass es
unzählige internationale Interessen in
dieser Region gibt und die jüngsten
Ereignisse könnten zu einem ernsthaften
Problem auf der internationalen agend
werden doch welche Interessen genau
stehen im Südkaukasus auf dem Spiel wie
könnte Aserbeidschan schließlich
Bergkarabach übernehmen stellt dies
wirklich das endgültige Ende des
langjährigen Konflikts zwischen Armenien
und Aserbaidschan da heute werden wir
alle diese Fragen natürlich beantworten
vorher habe ich aber noch eine wichtige
Frage an euch erinnert ihr euch noch an
die Schräge holzkernwerbung mit der wir
euch im Sommer zum Lachen gebracht haben
tada und schon ist Weihnachten wie
schnell doch die Zeit vergeht wie gesagt
waren viele Zuschauer von unserem kurzen
Clip damals ziemlich begeistert und wie
wir von Holzkern gehört haben
anschließend auch von ihren schönen
Produkten da wussten wir aber noch nicht
dass es jetzt noch besser kommt denn
stellt euch vor pünktlich zu Weihnachten
bietet holzern unserer Community ein
noch wesentlich besseres Angebot um auch
wirklich alle von den Vorzügen ihrer
tollen Uhren und Accessoires zu
überzeugen denn falls Du unseren Link in
der Beschreibung dem Video nutzt
erhältst du jetzt zu Weihnachten einen
Rabatt von 15% auf alle holzkernprodukte
außerdem falls du bis zum 20 Dezember
bestellst garantiert Holzkern die
Lieferung rechtzeitig zu Heiligabend und
sollte das Geschenk dann doch nicht
passen sind retur und Umtausch
selbstverständlich bis Ende Januar
möglich natürlich übernimmt Holzkern
auch die stilvolle Geschenkverpackung
und bietet schöne Geschenkbeutel und
extra für Weihnachten besondere
Geschenkboxen für eine persönliche
Nachricht gibt's sogar holzpostkarten
passend zu Weihnachten so kannst du
deine Lieben besonders preiswert und vor
allem stilvoll erfreuen außerdem gehst
du überhaupt kein Risiko ein oder du
nutzt die hohen Rabatte einfach für ein
Geschenk an dich selbst z.B ein
holzgernzeer das man sowieso schon lange
im Auge hatte fakt ist so gut wie jeder
von uns hier in der visualpolitik
Redaktion hat sich schon mindestens zwei
wunderschöne holzkenurren verliebt schon
beim Auspacken des liebevoll gestalteten
Päckchens merkt man dass die
österreichische Firma Holzkern ihr
ganzes Herzblut darin steckt dass
wirklich jede Facette perfekt sitzt und
gleichzeitig herrlich natürlich ist die
optimale Verbindung aus Präzision und
natürlicher Eleganz was will man mehr
von einer Uhr sofort fallen ein
natürlich die hochwertigen Materialien
auf aus den die Uhr gefertigt ist ihre
Maserung Marmorierung und das schillern
von Holz Stein und perlbot jedes Stück
ist von Natur aus ein Unikat die
Naturverbundenheit von Holzkern zeigt
sich jedoch nicht nur in ihren Produkten
sondern auch darin dass ihre Herstellung
Verpackung und die Lieferketten so
nachhaltig wie möglich gestaltet sind
also lass dir diese letzte Gelegenheit
vor Weihnachten nicht entgehen und
beglücke dich und deine Lieben mit dem
idealen Geschenk der Einzigartigkeit
einer holzkernuhr und oder mit einem
wunderschönen Accessoire aus dem
ebenfalls schön natürlich gestalteten
Schmuck und handtaschensortiment zögere
nicht zu lange denn Weihnachten steht
bereits vor der Tür so und wenn du deine
Weihnachts ein Kopf erledigt hast lass
uns wieder in unser Thema eintauchen
aufgepasst ein fast ewiger
Konflikt
Bergkarabach ist einer jeder
historischen Gebiete die im Laufe der
Geschichte durch unzählige verschiedene
Hände gegangen sind das mongolenreich
das Osmanische Reich das persische reich
und so weiter und so fort allerdings
findet sich in keiner dieser Episoden
der Ursprung des aktuellen Konflikts
dafür müssen wir nämlich an den
Zeitpunkt Reisen an dem die Sowjetunion
entstand mit dem Beginn des sowjetregims
wurde berkarabach das 1918 seine
Unabhängigkeit erklärt hatte und sich
weigerte Teil der 1917 gegründeten
transkaukasischen Republik Aserbaidschan
zu sein 1936 als autonome Region Teil
der aserbaidschanischen sozialistischen
Sowjetrepublik seitdem ist der Streit
zwischen Armenien und asseris in eine
Sackgasse geraten und wurde maßgeb vom
Kremmel gefördert der Grund Stalins
brutale Teile und herrscheepolitik aber
das ist ein Thema auf ein eigenes Video
spulen wir an dieser Stelle lieber
weiter vor bis zum Zerfall der
Sowjetunion mit dem bevorstehenden
Zerfall der Sowjetunion stimmten die
Einwohner von Bergkarabach überwiegend
ethnische Armenier 1988 in einem
Referendum für den Anschluss an die
armenische sozialistische Sowjetrepublik
Aserbeidschan lehnte dies ab und
schickte seine Truppen in das Gebiet der
erste bergkarabachkrieg hatte begonnen
der 1994 nach russischer Vermittlung
beendet wurde er kostete etwa 30 000
Menschen das Leben führte zu
Hunderttausenden von Vertriebenen und
dazu dass Armenien die Kontrolle über
Bergkarabach und sieben weitere
benachbarte Provinzen
Übernahmen von diesem Moment an wurde
Bergkarabach zu einer der
angespanntesten und konfliktreichsten
Regionen der Welt zwar hatte Armenien
erreicht dass Bergkarabach nicht von
Aserbaidschan kontrolliert wurde aber
das aserbaidschanische Regime wollte
nicht
aufgeben
obwohl beide Länder verschiedene
Verhandlungsprozesse eingeleitet haben
um eine Lösung für den Konflikt zu
finden war in Wirklichkeit keine der
beiden Seiten bereit aus historischen
Gründen nachzugeben und am Ende geschah
das was alle befürchtet hatten ein neuer
Krieg im Jahr 2016 testeten beide Länder
ihre Kräfte erneut mit heftigen
Zusammenstößen die vier Tage lang
dauerten trotzdem brach erst 2020 wieder
ein richtiger Krieg aus am 27 September
begann Aserbaidschan mit dem Beschuss
von Bergkarabach so begann der zweite
Karabach Krieg der 44 Tage dauerte 4000
armenische und aserbaidschanische
Soldaten das Leben kostete und mehr als
100.000 Karabach Armenier Vertrieb
dieser Krieg endete mit einem neuen
Abkommen das wieder einmal von Russland
vorangetrieben wurde im September 2023
wurden wir allerdings einmal mehr Zeuge
des eklattanten Scheiterns der
Waffenstillstandsvereinbarung zwischen
diesen beiden Ländern Aserbeidschan
brach das Abkommen und übernahm die
Kontrolle und warum scheiterte das
Abkommen dieses Mal gab es wirklich
einen echten Friedenswillen zwischen den
beiden Parteien was sind die
Konsequenzen dieser und all das schauen
wir uns jetzt mal
an das siegreiche
Aserbaidschan Armenien und Aserbaidschan
sind wie zwei starköpfige Brüder die
sich einfach weigern ein Centimeter
nachzugeben wenn Sie beide dasselbe
wollen und in diesem Fall ist dies Berg
Karabach im Laufe der Jahre hat es
zahlreiche Waffenstillstände gegeben die
immer mehr oder weniger gescheitert sind
deshalb hatten die meisten analsten
recht als sie vorher ges gesagt haben
dass auch der 2020 vereinbarte
Waffenstillstand irgendwann scheitern
würde und die Wahrheit ist dass dieses
Abkommen von Anfang an eher
problematisch
war schon zu Beginn der Verhandlungen
Wiesen sowohl Armenien als auch
Aserbaidschan auf erhebliche
Unstimmigkeiten im Text des Abkommens
hin während z.B ein Artikel beiden
Ländern erlaubte die im Konflikt
gewonnenen Gebiete bis zum Zeitpunkt der
Unterzeichnung des Abkommens zu behalten
wie se ein ander auf die Verpflichtung
der armenischen Truppen zum Rückzug hin
und dazu gesellten sich noch eine Menge
Probleme bei der Umsetzung des Abkommens
Armenien z.B weigerte sich der
Einrichtung des sansigurkorridors im
Süden des Landes zuzustimmen außerdem
weigerten sich beide Länder allen durch
den Konflikt Vertriebenen Menschen die
sichere Rückkehr in ihre Heimat zu
ermöglichen selbst mit der Unterstützung
des UNHCR Russland war eigentlich als
garantiemacht für die Überwachung des
Friedens zwischen den beiden Ländern im
Bereich des humanitären Korridors von
lain der Armenien mit Bergkarabach
verbindet und an der Grenze zwischen den
beiden Ländern zuständig aber es zeigte
sich dass die russischen
Friedenssoldaten nie in der Lage waren
die Truppen der beiden Länder effektiv
voneinander zu
[Musik]
trennen sowohl Armenien als auch
Aserbeidschan waren sich bewusst dass
das Abkommen ein Disaster war und sahen
daher die Möglichkeit eines neuen
Konflikts in der Zukunft voraus denn
wisst ihr was das
Waffenstillstandsabkommen von 2020 in
Wirklichkeit bewirkt hat anstatt Frieden
zu schaffen nun es führte dazu dass sich
beide Länder noch mehr bewaffneten es
ist wieder mal ein perfektes Beispiel
dafür wie Waffenstillstände zu noch mehr
Blutvergießen führen können wie ihr
allerdings sehen könnt waren die
Investitionen in absoluten Zahlen auf
aserbaidschanischer Seite viel höher
schließlich hatte dieses Land im Jahr
2020 ein mehr als dreimal so hohes BP
wie Armenien und das alles dank seines
bedeutenden Ölsektors außerdem war das
Volumen der aserbaidschanischen
waffenimporter zwischen 2011 und 2020
achtm höher als das
Armeniens und wie ihr euch vorstellen
könnt haben die Spannungen aufgrund des
unausgegorenen Abkommens von 2020 und
durch die starke Aufrüstung beider
Länder nur zugenommen Mitte September
2020 Griff Aserbeidschan z.B Regionen im
Süden Armeniens an dieser september in
dem fast 300 Menschen starben und 7600
Armenier vertrieben wurden stellte den
schlimmsten Monat seit dem Krieg im Jahr
2020 da und das war noch lange nicht
alles im Dezember 2020 beschlossen die
aserbaidschanischen Behörden den
humanitären Korridor von lain der
Bergkarabach mit Armenien verbindet zu
blockieren und dies führte natürlich zu
schwerwiegenden Folgen für die
Bevölkerung karabachs wir uns zu Tode
Bewohner von Bergkarabach fürchten unter
der Blockade um ihre Zukunft die
Menschen werden ohnmächtig und warten
auf Brot die Blockade die 120 000
Menschen durch den Bergkarabach Konflikt
isoliert die Aggression Aserbaidschans
bestätigten ein fast absolutes Gefühl
der Straffreiheit aserbeitschan musste
praktisch keine Konsequenzen fürchten
und wahrscheinlich deshalb rückten am 19
September 2023 aserbeidschanische
Truppen in Bergkarabach
ein Baku brauchte 24 Stunden um die
volle Kontrolle über das Gebiet zu
übernehmen und 24 Stunden vergingen bis
sich die Angst vor einer möglichen
ethnischen Säuberung gegen die Karabach
Armenia verbreitete das hatte natürlich
unmittelbare Folgen mehr als 100.000
Menschen haben Bergkarabach verlassen
etwa 120.000 Armenier lebten in der
Region bevor Aserbaidschan sie in einer
Blitzaktion zurückeroberte die die
Auflösung der separatistischen Republik
erzwangen aserbidschan besteht natürlich
darauf dass die Entscheidung der
etthnischen Karabach Armenier ihre
Heimat zu verlassen vollkommen
freiwillig war aber wenn wir uns die
Erfolgsbilanz des aserbaidschanischen
Regimes ansehen müssen wir feststellen
dass diese Menschen sicherlich keine
andere Wahl hatten vergesst bitte nicht
dass Aserbaidschan von einem autoritären
Regime beherrscht wird in dem
Menschenrechte und individuelle
Freiheiten keine Rolle spielen ein
Regime das seit Jahrzehnen den Hass auf
Armenia pflegt und nicht zgörte sie
verhungern zu lassen als es den
lachtinkorridor Schloss und das Ergebnis
ist eben dass Aserbaidschan nun
vollständig Bergkarabach kontrolliert es
scheint als ob der längste der
postsowjetischen Konflikte zu einem Ende
gekommen ist aber trotzdem bleibt eine
Frage offen und diese lautet wie wirkt
sich das alles auf die Mächte in der
Nähe des Südkaukasus aus sind die
feinseligkeiten dieser Region wirklich
ein für alle mal vorbei nun ihr merkt
schon diese Frage ist rein rhetorisch
und deswegen sehen wir uns die ganze
Geschichte jetzt mal ganz genau an
aufgepasst ein kaukasischer Kalter
Krieg
ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass viele
von euch schon einmal gedacht haben
dieser Konflikt sei eher unbedeutend nur
ein weiterer Konflikt in einer anderen
verlorenen Region der Welt denn noch
Maline lieben visualpolitik Zuschauer
könnte die Realität ganz anders aussehen
wusstet ihr eigentlich dass der
armenisch-aserbaidschanische
bergkarabachkonflikt ein lebendiges
Spiegelbild der Spannungen zwischen
Russland und der Türkei ist was in
Karabach passiert ist ein perfektes
Beispiel für den russischen Niedergang
und und den türkischen Aufstieg in der
Region und warum nun seht es euch
an Russland ist seit dem Zerfall der
Sowjetunion zweifellos der aktivsteer
Akteur im Südkaukasus tatsächlich gelang
es Moskau 1994 Aserbaidschan und
Armenien zu einem Waffenstillstand zu
bewegen der Kremmel hat sich allerdings
Armenien gegenüber solidarischer gezeigt
als gegenüber Aserbaidschan so
unterzeichneten die beiden Länder 1997
ein Militärbündnis das den Bau von
Stützpunkten Armenien bis 2044 erlaubt
außerdem wurde Armenien Teil der
Organisation des Vertrages über
kollektive Sicherheit die von Russland
geleitet wird es handelt sich um so
etwas wie die russische NATO und wir
haben mal ein Video über sie gedreht
allerdings ist diese russische NATO
nicht mehr als ein Schatten ihrer selbst
die Unterstützung seiner Verbündeten
durch Moskau ist in den letzten Jahren
immer schlechter geworden im Jahr 2020
hat Russland z.B beschlossen eine im
wesentlichen neutrale Rolle
beizubehalten um seine eigenen
Interessen zu waren und auf dem letzten
Treffen dieser Organisation ist Armenien
erst gar nicht erschienen und zwar
demonstrativ und vielleicht sollten wir
auch nicht vergessen dass Russland die
ganzen Jahre über der wichtigste
waffenlieferand beider Länder
[Musik]
war die gleiche Neutralität hat Russland
auch angesichts der jüngsten Ereignisse
an den Tag gelegt aber wahrscheinlich
hatten sie angesichts der Verluste in
der Ukraine und der Bindung der Truppen
dort keine andere Wahl armenien ist sich
dieser Situation bewusst und hat
deswegen versucht sich immer weiter
Washington anzunäheren was in Moskau
natürlich nicht gut ankam Armeniens
Verrat wie Russlands großer verbündete
sich den USA annäherte die armenische
Regierung hat angesichts der wachsenen
Spannungen mit Aserbaidschan im
bergkarabachkrieg Militärübungen mit den
USA begonnen mit anderen Worten mit der
Entfremdung Armeniens von Russland hat
die Rolle des kremels im Südkaukasus
immer mehr ein Einfluss verloren und je
ansicher schon wer diese Chance nutzen
konnte ja genau Reb tayib
Erdogan
[Musik]
die Türkei ist traditionell der beste
Verbündete Aserbaidschans im Jahr 2009
unterzeichnete sie z.B einen Vertrag der
sie dazu verpflichtet sich gegenseitig
zu schützen falls einer der beiden
Staaten von einem anderen Land
angegriffen wird und es überrascht nicht
dass die türkische Hilfe vor allem in
Form von Waffen nach Aserbaidschan kam
F16 Kampfflugzeuge infanteriefahrzeuge
und vor allem
beiaktadrohen tatsächlich waren
Aserbaidschans große Erfolge im Krieg
2020 vor allem der türkischen Hilfe zu
verdanken auch wenn israelische Waffen
ebenfalls eine große Rolle gespielt
haben und was ist der Grund für die
türkische Unterstützung nun die Türkei
hat starke Interessen in der Region
Interessen die durch Aserbaidschans
jüngsten Sieg in Bergkarabach noch
weiter gefördert wurden aber von welchen
Interessen sprechen wir hier überhaupt
nun um zu verstehen was die Türkei mit
der Unterstützung aserbeidschans
bezweckt müssen wir zunächst einmal
verstehen dass der Südkaukasus ein
Gebiet von besonderer strategischer
Bedeutung ist wie ihr dieser Karte nur
unschwer entnehmen könnt liegt es
zwischen dem schwarzen und dem
kaspischen mehr das heißt es
kontrolliert den transportfluss der
Region von Osten nach Westen und
umgekehrt aber auch von Norden nach
Süden nämlich von Russland zu anderen
Ländern am Indischen Ozean es ist genau
diese entscheidende Zone in der die
Türkei einen größeren Einfluss als
Russland haben möchte und zwar aus einem
einzigen Grund um die Verbindung zu
Zentralasien herzustellen die Türkei
möchte sich über das Kaspische Meer
direkt mit der riesigen asiatischen
Region verbinden um von den großen
Erdgasreserven türkmenistan zu
profitieren und neue seehandelsprojekte
anzukurbeln und wisst ihr woran die
Türkei in der Region noch interessiert
ist nun an nichts Geringerem als eine
andere benachbarte Macht zu überholen
den
[Musik]
Iran und ihr fragt euch vielleicht
moment mal was hat der Iran damit zu tun
nun ihr müsst verstehen dass der Iran
auch versucht seine Position im
Südkaukasus zu stärken um eine neue
Handelsroute vom persischen Golf nach
Georgien zu eröffnen ziel ist es von
Georgien aus eine neue Verbindung mit
mit Russland und Europa über das
Schwarze Meer herzustellen allerdings
befürchtet man in Teheran dass
Aserbeidschan versuchen könnte seinen
Sieg über Armenien auszunutzen um weiter
in die Region vorzudringen das könnte
nämlich sogar s weit gehen dass sie den
iranen den Weg nach Armenien versperren
sie könnten alle Pläne der herans
durchkreuzen wenn Sie den
sandsigurkorridor schließen und deshalb
hat sich der Iran zu Gunsten Armeniens
positioniert und wird dies auch
weiterhin tun vor allem die Präsenz des
Irans bleibt nie unbemerkt wisst ihr
welches andere Land nur wegen der
Interessen des Irans in dieses Chaos
verwickelt ist genau einer seiner
größten geopolitischen Rivalen Israel
tatsächlich war Israel im Jahr 2020 der
zweitgrößte waffenhandelspartner
Aserbaidschans und lieferte rund 27% der
Waffen an das kaukasische Land bisher
war Israels Rolle in der Region
allerdings nicht so entscheiden wie die
der Türkei oder Russlands aber das
könnte sich bald
ändern nach der plötzlichen Eskalation
der Feindseligkeiten zwischen Israel und
dem Iran nach dem brutalen
Terroranschlag der Hamas ist die
geopolitische Szene im nahen und im
Mittleren Osten wieder in aufruh geraten
dabei sollten wir nicht vergessen dass
der Iran nicht nur enge Verbindungen
zuur hesballah im Libanon sondern eben
auch zu Hamas im Gazastreifen hat wir
haben sogar ein eigenes Video darüber
gedreht wie stark er hinter dem Anschlag
der Hamas und ihrer Aufrüstung steckt
und sollten die Feindseligkeiten weiter
eskalieren ist es sehr wahrscheinlich
dass sowohl Israel als auch der Iran
ihren besonderen Kalten Krieg so weit
verschärfen dass er auch den Südkaukasus
betrifft denn der Iran und Israel
verfügen über keine gemeinsame Grenz
also haben die Israelis bereits in der
Vergangenheit Aserbaidschan als Basis
genutzt um in Iran zu operieren und
deswegen unterstützt Israel
Aserbaidschan und der Iran unterstützt
Armenien tja wie ihr seht scheint
Aserbaidschan mit dem Bergkarabach
Konflikt ein für alle mal fertig zu sein
er hat bereits das gesamte Gebiet
übernommen und Armenien scheint nicht
genug Kräfte zu haben um die Situation
zu ändern allerdings laufen Armenien und
Aserbaidschan wähen sich dieser Konflikt
seinem Ende zunigt Gefahr in das Spiel
von Großmächten wie Russland der Türkei
dem Iran und Israel verwickelt zu werden
nur die Zeit wird zeigen wie weit die
Lage noch weiter eskaliert und deswegen
behalten wir die Region im Blick
vergesst also bitte nicht das Abo um
unsere künftigen Videos dazu nicht zu
verpassen aber bis dahin sind die Fragen
erstmal an euch gerichtet glaubt ihr
dass Armenien in Zukunft wieder
versuchen könnte Bergkarabach irgendwie
zurückz erobern könnte Russland seinen
Einfluss im Südkaukasus auch irgendwie
wieder zurückgewinnen wird diese kleine
Region zu einem showplatz für einen
indirekten Konflikt zwischen dem Iran
und Israel es würde mich sehr freuen
wenn ihr eure Meinung zu diesem Thema
mit uns und auch mit den anderen
Zuschauern teilen würdet ich hoffe dass
euch dies Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht auch das dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt uns bitte ein Like Teil
mit euren Freunden und diskutiert es mit
ihnen vergiss bitte auch nicht das tolle
Weihnachtsangebot von Holzkern mit
satten 15% Rabatt stilvoller
Geschenkverpackung und Rückgaberecht bis
Ende Januar wenn du den Link unter dem
Video nutzt natürlich freuen wir uns
auch jederzeit über eine
Weihnachtsspende von euch mit der uns
helft dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den
Link dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut und bis
bald
[Musik]